don't you have like that's okay now cut
out that wasn't mean I guess don't watch
this what is a replay for no valid
reason in regards to skateboarding jump
off the end is just a montage of us is
like you're seeing like a share song
alright we're gonna have to get Daniel
to make a mash-up of shares I believe in
life after love and I believe I can can
that be your theme song that will be my
theme song this did it did it it Bob and
then also
right do anything you cut to a splash
screen and with like a Looney Tunes
background I just like song starts
playing oh that makes sense that goes
back to where you were I saw the rib oh
okay that right I was only four days oh
you okay King on the official market
fire
laugh track CD doors man your wife can
cheat on you and I couldn't drown all my
children and it's apparently that's what
people do when they're away that's it oh
my god every every Sims video I've ever
seen is always like today I want to show
you an exploit if you build a pool and
have a pool party and then uninstall the
ladder is the most monotone let's vote
all right okay everybody why are all the
ramps off the side to other parts of the
park obviously I want to kill myself
video game what's the point I have
really good impressions of lots of
youtubers oh okay give me captain
sparkles first yeah that's good who else
who else do I have
hello everyone this is yummy mushy
we're gonna play pokemon emerald green
why not doing that right now everybody
change your mind Wingardium okay oh I
apologize for that word you said but I'm
gonna sue my god